frédéric le ou la succession de trisomie
sur un ami le 20 juillet par le parti
conservateur d'ici là encore plus des
certitudes alors que bâti ou que peut-il
se passer avec les briques c'est bien
des choses claudine vous allez sûrement
tremblay d'impatience puisque on devrait
en savoir plus en fête le 31 octobre
2019 dont soir de l'halloween
c'est l'échéance ultime supposé là pour
savoir ce qui arrive avec le break site
alors est-ce qu'on va vers un soft
briques site wordpress sites comme
disent les britanniques mais tout dépend
évidemment du prochain locataire du 10
downing street à londres est ce que ce
serait effectivement boris johnson ou
une autre personne qui va succéder à
thierry sam est en tout cas à tous les
scénarios sont sur la table le premier
se serait bon qu'il n'y ait pas d'accord
donc le fameux nous dit on c'est à dire
que le royaume uni va quitter l'union
européenne sans déterminer quoi que ce
soit c'est pas l'idéal mais c'est une
position qui existe actuellement
l'autre à l'extrême la l'extrême de du
décide de la décision d'un odile ce
serait que on efface tout et on oublie
ce fameux bric site c'est peu probable
mais encore une fois c'est envisageable
mais aussi la possibilité d'un autre
référendum pour s'assurer que les
britanniques ont bien compris qu'elles
étaient les tenants et les aboutissants
encore là qui voudra s'aventurer là
dedans
un rien n'est moins sûr ou alors il y a
toujours la possibilité de déclencher
des élections pour que le prochain
gouvernement est un mandat fort pour
mener tout ça à bien d'ici le 31 octobre
ce qui est sûr en tout cas c'est qu'il
n'y aura pas de renégociation pour une
autre une autre échéance puisque l'union
européenne a dit qu'il n'en n'était
vraiment pas question je vous rappelle
quand même que tout ça a commencé
c'était au mois de juin 2016 le 23 juin
que les britanniques ont dit oui à
l'idée de quitter justement l'union
européenne donc c'est en quelque sorte
là que tout a commencé avec ce fameux
divorce des britanniques avec l'union
européenne c'est-à-dire il ya 46 ans il
entrait dans l'union européenne et là
ils ont dû baisser terminé donc tout
ceci est assez particulier et en plus
pas plus tard qu'hier claudine
rappelez-vous les britanniques ont voté
pourquoi mais pour élire des députés au
parlement européen vous voyez que c'est
complètement surréaliste ce qu'ils font
c'est un oui à 52% ou c'est sacré aussi
beaucoup d'incertitudes et de
tiraillements c'est très polarisée merci
beaucoup aux frais d entrée au revoir